aurélien allemand moi c'est les viandes
tu m'appelleras tellement c'était
paraissait départ rêve c'était pas un
rêve mais aussi elle a passé une bonne
soirée je suis amoureux je crois qu'on
est à 4 grammes on est souvent amoureux
c'est pas vrai j'ai pas douter le
dernier chiffre
c'est pas compliqué c'est mathématique
il suffit d'envoyer un texto des numéros
potentiel ça fait deux ans que je
retourne paris qui a que des loosers eh
bien il ya des mecs mac et on est
heureuses vivions au cul j'ai rencontré
quelqu'un il va donner son numéro que
j'ai mal notés du coup j'essaye de le
retrouver ces envois décès mais ça mon
mec et tu fais ta sainte
je suis désolé je connais pas cet homme
là un tackle ray soixante dix numéros
appelés va lui falloir un plus grand
tableau quelques rendez-vous dans un
café romantique et enchanté mademoiselle
parle-nous un petit peu de toi qu'est ce
qui t'a amené à rejoindre les
alcooliques anonymes
je ne devrais pas être là personne ne
devrait être là
faut absolument que je ne retrouve ses
sûreté lui l'homme de ma vie amar
l'amour ne se trouve à personne a la
poisse comme moi franchement il faut que
tu arrêtes de tomber amoureuse de tous
les mecs que tu croises suite au côté
bohème c'est quoi en fait que tu
comprends pas le sens bien c'est laisser
le bon tu peux aller voir ma kiné
dernière fois à masser le mollet gban
des sourcils du mollet non je crois pas
que le problème vienne du palais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]